oh look at this legendary yeah oh my god
look at that yep
my brother took that picture hold on
look at his slinging dick days yo
yeah dude a hundred percent oh
my god bro all these stories that makes
so much more sense when you see
this guy yeah dude because then now you
see him as this more agile [ __ ]
let's do it all you know yo so when i
met him he was 225 pounds
he would go on stage in a three-piece
suit
um and he paced like crazy really
he paced like and he did this with his
hand all the time
so he made the people in the front row
kind of uncomfortable
because he was an intimidating dude you
know what i mean
hey josh theo it's brad from vancouver
canada hey brad
josh question for you what is the uh the
craziest story you have
about living with joey diaz gang gang
gang brother
all right i got a couple questions first
of all did he need to be shirtless for
the
question or i think it makes him feel
look i can't i can't make it through a a
good television program i can't make
through an episode of the wire without
taking my shirt off well yeah but that's
personal
you know what i mean that's something
where you're like i feel like i need to
breathe well i just need to yeah yeah
yeah
i do like the fact that he might have
squeezed his nipple a little bit right
towards the end so i like this dude
that's that nervous habit baby and here
i will tell you
uh my favorite joe diaz stories come
from you know he used to babysit my kids
right and um did you guys ever do the
road together
yeah man he sold me once for a bag of
weed did he really
for sex or what yo so pre-phones
we might have had pagers me him and a
guy named lenny schmidt
lenny was living in seattle at the time
but he's out of chicago black guy
nope a irish dude bring up lenny schmidt
i just want to know visually who we're
even thinking about um
i don't want to be thinking and and be
wrong
that yeah that's there you go there you
go oh he was in joe dirt
oh lenny huh yeah wow there you go lenny
schmidt
so me joe diaz lenny schmidt we drive
down to roseburg
washington we do a one-nighter
um and uh we're out of the bar
afterwards
and we're sitting um as joe diaz called
her he was like
we gonna bring that girl who looks like
me with a wig i'm like yeah we're gonna
she wanted to come i was like yeah we'll
bring her she was driving too you know
so we go to this bar i go to the
bathroom i come back joey and lenny are
gone
and i'm sitting there for a second and
we were talking me and the girl for a
little while
and then finally i'm like where where jo
and lenny
and she said oh joey sold you for a bag
of weed and i was like what i thought it
was a joke
and sh because he said where can i get
some weed i don't have a lot of money
and she said i can get you a bag of weed
but you got to leave your friend
damn why you're in the while you're in
the john and he said
deal so i come out
and i'm like your property now yeah i
was like well i don't know how that's
going to work oh this is jim crow
yeah yeah i was like well i don't know
if i'm down with that you know
because she really look she was not
my that was not my style she was not
i and by the way i'm not i always dated
bigger girls so big what isn't an issue
for me like
i i always said like i like a girl with
a
with a big ass i like to see the wave
you know what i mean
i i i have a big mouth so i like my
girls to be a little bigger just in case
there's a fight you know what i mean
yeah and beth is the first girl that i
ever dated that was
i like him a little bigger so this girl
being big wasn't a problem
just the entire situation you weren't
attracted to her
yeah yeah she goes i go let me drive me
back to that hotel she goes oh
okay was she nice was she cool yeah
until we get back to her place oh yeah
now why'd you go to her place i think he
said hotel okay i go yeah take me back
to hotel she was cool
and i don't know anything about this
place she goes hey i just need to swing
past my
place real quick to get some more weed
for you guys and then i'll
drive you to the hotel and i'm like
perfect more weed how much you guys
gonna smoke i guess you got joey witch
i figured joey it's gone by the time i
get to the hotel do you know what i mean
that's smoke emotive baby you dude
i showed up at that house and we park
she goes into room to get we
she comes out in this crazy lingerie
dancing like the guy from silence of the
lamb
oh yeah you know what i mean yeah yeah
but like but like
let me give you an idea the the body
type like the belly was bigger than the
boobs
oh yeah you know and no booty and so
and and that's that tampa dude that's
that tampa oh yeah
that's that del ray beach yeah mom dude
but yeah but i'm gonna go even worse
short curly hair oh yeah yeah you know
what i mean the whole package was not
yeah but she's dancing in this lingerie
and i'm like hey i gotta
yeah yeah i gotta and she goes let me
try some nails on she and i was like no
no no
so she goes back in and i'm looking for
yellow pages because i'm like i'm going
to call a cab
she comes out with another one she's
running her finger over my cheek at this
point it's feeling
kind of rapey yeah because i'm like
she's definitely
double my weight like i think i could
outrun her but she's got a car
yeah and she's bigger than me yeah you
can't just run off in the distance
so like this guy there's a buffalo bill
dancing her roommate comes home
with her boyfriend he walks in
and i stop at the door i go hey man we
don't know each other but you got to get
me out of here
okay and he was like what i go i told
him the situation she comes out in her
third outfit
and he looks at her and looks at the
girl's roommate and the girl's roommate
goes you mind your own business
and the guy was like i gotta take him
home i can't i can't do i can't do this
dude
no he got coded me and i was like thanks
dude he goes yeah i may not have sex
tonight but i'm gonna save you i was
like dude
thank you so much we didn't drive dude
we didn't talk on the way
to the hotel i just kind of looked out
the window like one tear like it was a
traumatizing
but he dropped me off and he and we just
fist bumped didn't say anything
i walked to the room i knocked on the
door i go joe diaz
he was like who is it i go you know
and i was like give me some of that weed
he was like now we smoked we smoked all
that dog
yeah he sold me for weeds was asleep in
my bed
ate my food in my room and then was like
hey can you drive i'm tired
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one